[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the group chat live in the
bleacher report app presented by
fanduel we have a double header tonight
game three for the bucks in the nets
game two for the jazz
and the clippers my name is cabbie
richards she's tapped into more
analytics than sixers general manager
daryl mori that is aaron dolan and back
from miami it's the man of the people
greg
ivory welcome to you both um greg we
know you've been hitting a bunch of
not a bunch but a few big parlays
recently
because you've been overly generous with
the merch
uh will that continue today
of course cabbie is today i mean is the
sky blue
is today thursday yes to both answers
therefore we are continuing giving away
merch i got hoodies i got jerseys going
to hook
four of you up with 125 to pick out
whatever jersey you want
and i'm giving that first one um right
now
let me introduce the new people to the
show this right here
cabbie aaron is the handy dandy ipad and
this is how you win your jerseys
and hoodies i'm in the comments cabbie i
am in the comments
i see uh coffee black sending good vibes
coffee black she says coffee black 1077
says
kd is scoring 31.
actually this is bad boss i'm so sorry
this is bad vibes but
uh he said kd scoring 31 kyrie scoring
26 that equals 57 points he's going with
the under we want the over i'm so sorry
i gotta go selling theogre coffee black
you're you're going to walk away with a
hoodie coffee black but i got somebody
else right here cabbie
slim reaper slim reaper 22 says 64.
oh my god that's more bad vibes oh my
god
i haven't even we haven't even gotten to
that part of the show yet my g
even though we didn't post it on yeah
but on in the app earlier
they know kevin i'm looking for good
vibes in the comments all right here we
go
finn sanity finn sanity five finn sanity
five
you're walking away with a jersey he
says 74 points tonight for kd
kyrie cabbie they know they know about
the vibes were they we posted it on the
story uh
the thumbnail on the app we're riding me
over here okay so but
for the people that are just joining the
stream who who didn't tap in with the
social posts
uh look the the brooklyn nets have
really assembled a team of
avengers because their superstars play
like
superheroes and they have the best pure
shooter in the nba raining down threes
the nets have a nice two-nothing cushion
without james harden
which is wild to think about so today in
the vr app as g-money mentioned we asked
you
to drop your best guess for kyrie and
kevin durant's combined points
now fanduel is offering a br betting
odds boost on their combined points
total let's take a look at the graphic
here so it went from
plus 150 boosted to plus 200 will
kyrie irving and kevin durant the kanye
west of the nba
and the slim reaper score 65 points or
more
tonight in milwaukee that is the
question
uh g money you've been on the nets for a
few months now
and i lost another hundred dollar bet to
you i just
this is a this is a show where we have
some full disclosure so
earlier today i lost 100 bet to you
because you said back in december before
hardin was traded
that the nets will win the championship
they're in the driver's seat right now
so
uh i'll get that to you uh when we get
paid okay so anyway
um we know your dude is kevin durant are
there other people in the comments whose
dude is
also kevin durant and think the 65 point
marker plateau is in is in view for
that dynamic duo cabbie earlier i saw
not a lot of good vibes but hopefully
the vibes have changed you know the show
started we're into it a little bit uh
hopefully the vibes change but let me
talk to the people
get in the comments and tell me how many
points will kyrie
and katie put up tonight combined i'm
giving away hoodies
to the best commenters at the end
no actually i'm going to give away a
jersey at the end of the game tonight
i'm gonna give away a jersey we'll dm
you guys
we'll dm you guys i'll give away a
jersey at the end of the game tonight
uh aaron how many do you think kai e
kyrie and katie are putting up tonight
so in this series already kd is
averaging 31 kyrie 24 and since these
two games were
played in brooklyn i had to take it back
to when the next played in milwaukee
that was may
2nd and may 4th now the nets lost both
those games
but in those games the first one kd
dropped 42 kyrie 20
then that second game kitty dropped 32
and kyrie had 38 so both these players
can go off in milwaukee
i'm not worried about that so give me
over 65.
you're not why that's 65 is kind of a
high total even though as you said aaron
they can both go off
tonight i'm i'm leaning on the under
look the bucks were embarrassed
in game two they were down by as many as
49 points
they were lit up rightfully so on
national television
sports radio basketball twitter
all over the place so this is a gut
check game for the milwaukee bucks on
their home court in game three
kyrie irving and the slim reaper are
basically impossible to stop
but they can be contained holzer
is gonna adjust the lineups a little bit
and he's gotta start throwing some
different looks
at the wall or just throw out maybe bryn
forbes to get the offense start give a
little bit more juice
um in lieu of some defense but listen
i'm saying
under 65 points tonight in game three
uh g-money are you locking in this
specific bet katie kyrie
65 or more as offered by fanduel
cabbie i am in the comments let me get
in the comments then i'll give my take
i got uh not ronald acuna junior says
forty four
thirty eight for tyree yes he's back not
ronaldo cooner jr says 78 points in
total those are good
vibes good that's what i'm talking about
wow it's good it's it's a good vibe it's
all about the world
i got i got nh no in inhale
inhale 24 says uh he's going with 70.
70 for the dub for kyrie and uh kd shout
out to you
and he'll you're walking away with a
hoodie uh i got one more
one more cabbie one more i got j3 21
says katie
43 kyrie 25
totaling 68. therefore uh
those are good vibes and i'm going to
keep the good vibes going here
uh we have kyrie irving who is an
automatic
bucket and we also have kevin durant who
is also
an automatic bucket they have been
balling they have been balling
uh in the first two games that's up 2-0
i don't see what's going to change kathy
i i really don't see what's going to
change i think they're going to have a
high scoring game today
i'm taking the over it's plus 200 give
me the plus money
let's go here we go we're riding
together like gotta take it a plus money
it's plus 200.
yeah that's 200 that's a good that's a
good boost maybe uh
you guys are both on that good good like
inhale what's that commenter's name
inhale
420 anyway let's keep it moving uh for
the second year to roll
the milwaukee bucks are down 0-2 in a
playoff series
here we are in year eight the
26-year-old greek god
yana santa zakumpo in milwaukee here's
the question
do you believe he's gonna win an nba
championship
for that city you're eight you're nine
or beyond uh let's take a look at the
odds for this year's
championship title the leaders in the
clubhouse
brooklyn nets followed by the number one
overall seed in the nba
the utah jazz phoenix is up to nothing
in its series against denver they're
writing a mix
there's a great value in the middle
middle of the pack clippers
sixers bucks and then some super long
shots
the atlanta hawks and the o2 denver
nuggets
uh g-money are you giving away hoodies
or jerseys this time
both get in the comments and tell me
what you
tell me if you think that giannis will
win a ring with milwaukee this year
or ever aaron talk to me talk to me talk
to me
what do you think well as we just saw
this year or ever sorry no you're good i
honestly i don't know if they're ever
going to win it which is giannis by
himself i mean the bucks are 16-1 as we
just saw to win the nba championship and
boy did they slip down the odds words
i don't think giannis wins a ring with
milwaukee this year at all you know a
good friend of mine as i said
for the show said f the bucks and the f
is for fade in terms of betting but
after they beat miami we switched it to
f the bucks and the f is for finals now
cabbie and greg if the bucks are playing
a different team than the brooklyn nets
i would say there's
obviously some type of hope of them
actually winning a ring depending on who
was going to come out of the west this
year
but giannis the two-time mvp going
against kd kyrie i get harden is on the
bench right now but brooklyn is just so
good
and the honest truth to giannis is he
really just needs another superstar
around him in milwaukee
i mean i heard no lies and i'm gonna try
to make a case for
um milwaukee so i'm gonna say yes he
wins
a title with the bucks with this caveat
by next year because if he doesn't if he
doesn't win this year and there's still
time they're down 02. it's not
insurmountable
um and they're really missing dante d
vincenzo who was like their hustle guy
great on closeouts just a grinder
they're missing he's not
the reason they're down02 but he can he
can certainly help
help the squad but if they don't win
this year
head coach mike butenholzer is likely
getting fired so next year they'll have
a new coach
some new energy perhaps all be um
i'll be healthy but after that then it's
like if they don't year
win in 2022 if they don't win in 2021 i
think giannis is out because we've seen
superstars
force their way out of town we saw james
harden do it this year was trading on
january the 14th
russell westbrook he was he's a
franchise player john wall
and russell they did a flip-flop um
so there'll be some and we're hearing
about damien lillard potentially
forcing his way out of portland if he
doesn't get the the coach
that he wants so there's we love the
movement in the nba we love the hope
trafficking
so i'm saying yes giannis will win a
title
with milwaukee in 2021 or 2022
and if not he's out uh g-money we know
that brooklyn
is the squad that you selected to win
the nba championship so if that comes
true
do you think that giannis will win a
title with brooklyn next year or beyond
or ever
as you said so poetically
uh cabbie let me give away some jerseys
or one jersey and some hoodies and then
i'll get into my take are you giving
away honest jerseys
are we giving away with like if the fans
i'm
we're you know cabbie i'm a man of the
people i don't i don't you know i'm not
trying to
uh stray any fan to to pick one jersey i
want them to pick
any jersey so it's whatever jersey they
want we'll just give them the money for
the jersey that they want you know
but uh i got john schneider here john
schneider saying
nah fam giannis will not win a ring with
milwaukee shout out to you john
schneider you were walking away
with uh a sweatshirt uh
i got motivated motivated in the
comments giving us this new
the scooby-doo gift you guys see it
right there uh scooby-doo
saying no scooby-doo sing no motivated
shout out to you your walk away with
hoodie i think it's jersey time kevin i
think it's jersey time
i am in the comments and i see uh
i see oh this is funny
it's a lot of funny gifts but i got
jaylee right here
jaylee199 got the shannon sharp
uh no gift right there
hey hey jaylee199 you are walking away
with the jersey today uh now let me jump
in here
will no well we all know i don't think
that he's going to win this year
i i agree with aaron she says that he's
a piece away he's definitely a piece
away
uh from from winning a championship out
there in milwaukee do i
see that happening no i don't see it
happening in milwaukee cabbie
aaron i'll be honest i just don't see it
you're talking about getting rid of the
coach
they brought in drew holiday to be that
other superstar
with giannis i think they need something
else
i do think they need something else
chris middleton he's also a good player
they just need something else but i'll
tell you honest what to do gabby i'll
tell him what to do
he needs to be on the first private jet
from milwaukee to san francisco
to go talk to the splash brothers and
steph curry thompson
and then he might he might be
in conversations on winning multiple
championships
that's what he needs to do he's like
like frank ocean once sung what's a king
to a god the greek god isn't
he's he's not anybody's sidekick he's
nobody's rob into a batman and if he
goes
to golden state we obviously know that
steph curry is cemented
as he's approaching top 15 greatest of
all time
to ever play the sport so the greek
god's not going to
and also do you know how much do you
know how much flack
yeah onto the koopa would get like we
saw the happy storm
why kd guy why why would he get because
katie win
he's joined a 73 win team and he's i
don't
understand i don't i don't understand
this is what i don't understand
whenever a player comes to join the
warriors oh it's such a problem it's
such a problem we have
big threes in in new york i don't hear
them saying
nothing about that and they have i mean
james harden kyrie
irving slim no people have been talking
about the big three in brooklyn the
whole season
as soon as harding not not dating
they're not getting the warriors
they're not getting the warriors
treatment they're not getting the words
true the whole universe hated the
warriors for katie coming over
to the warriors like they're not it's
still love you see me i want to talk
about brooklyn because it's love
it's not the same it's not the same okay
well you're listening
you are a unique individual because
you're showing a lot of love
but we know sometimes in comment
sections and out there on basketball
twitter
a lot of haters and a lot of burner
accounts anyway we move on with the
group chat in uh in game
not saying that you have a bernard
account uh in game one uh
versus the la clippers donovan mitchell
scored more points than kawhi leonard
and paul george combined his 45 points
were the third most that he's ever
scored
in a playoff game in his career spider
mitchell was
on one so tonight is game two in front
of a packed house
at vivint arena in salt lake city so
let's talk about donovan mitchell's
points rebounds and assists g-money
before we get into this conversation you
have any more merch to give away
uh of course what do you want to say to
me but what i need every
woman what i need everybody to do what i
need everybody to do is get in the
comments and tell me how many
points rebounds and assists donovan
mitchell was putting up tonight
i'm gonna give away a hoodie and i got
one more jersey to give away
in the next segment erin are you on the
over or the
under here with donovan mitchell so
what's interesting is utah's head coach
quinn snyder said yes
yesterday that mitchell was actually
sick last game so it's interesting that
he had 45 points in that game
didn't play well in that first half but
obviously scored the first 10 points for
the jazz in the second
over 40 and a half i'm gonna of course
take that over like i just mentioned
even alone with just what he's averaging
during the regular season this could
potentially hit
and last game with his points alone he
was able to hit over 40 and a half so
i'm gonna go with the over there
before i get into donovan mitchell i
gotta salute rudy gobert for winning his
third
defensive player of the year award rudy
gobert in my opinion the stifle tower is
the most
important player on the utah jazz okay
so
uh and then we saw it you know in game
one
and at the end of the game he blocks
marcus morris like a center blocking a
dude on the perimeter three-point shot
it was magical
and uh you know g-money i will salute
draymond green
from your golden state warriors because
draymond green did it to kyle lowry in
game
five uh and that's the reason we didn't
win
uh we being the toronto raptors in five
games but anyway so salute to draymond
green
who has been incredible on inside the
nba so uh donovan mitchell
there's no mike conley today he's still
battling and hamstring injuries so there
are more opportunities
for diamond mitchell to pass the rock
and to rack up some assists
i think the rebounds are going to be
down under four because
gobert is in the middle and zubots and
marcus morris on the other side
um snagging some maybe not marcus morris
but zubots snagging some rebounds and
paul george and kawhi leonard
so he's not going to shoot 15
three-pointers again like he did in game
one
and he's not going to score 45 points
again so i'm gonna take the under
even though the number is definitely
within reach
under 40 and a half points rebounds and
an assist
for me uh will i bet on it i will bet on
it tonight why not
uh g-money what do you think about
spider-mitch's potential production
tonight in game two
cabbie uh i'll get to that i'll get to
that but i just have some fans
in the comments uh that want hoodies
so uh give it to him let me talk give it
to him let me talk to him real quick
i got not zach levine is in the comment
section over he's going to have
he's going to have at least 33
he can get six assists and two rebounds
i believe that is that over
yeah that is over that's that's barely
over that's barely over but that is over
shout out to you not zach levine you are
walking away
with the hoodie uh i got not monk not
monk not monk
says over for sure shout out to you
not monk you're rocking with the over
cabbie i'm trying to see if
you're getting any love with the under
here uh i'm in the comments and i see
ryan ray he says uh 34 points three
rebounds
and seven assists so that's over i think
that gets it done that's the over
are these guys are the people in the
comments forgetting that paul george
and kawhi leonard play for the la
clippers are they forgetting that
cabbie oh don't wait wait wait these are
two of the best winged offenders
it doesn't mean donovan mitchell is not
gonna hit this though
listen they're he's not going for 45.
he's gonna he's gonna get clamps put on
him and a bunch of bodies
uh thrown at him uh in game two
cabbie if this was august when when we
were in the bubble
uh last year i would be right there with
you i would be talking about the dogs
that are in
la yeah uh rocking that they're on this
clippers team
they still have dogs don't get me wrong
they're still dogs but they
they've been playing uh i don't know not
like
not like how i thought they would last
year in the bubble and not like how i uh
talked them up
last year in the bubble i don't know
what's going on in
l.a cabbie i do not know what's going on
paul george
kawhi leonard patrick beverly uh you
know the defensive stoppers out there
they just haven't really been
stopping anybody this playoffs they
haven't stopped luca
luca was absolutely balling at will
whenever he wanted to
they did not stop donovan mitchell okay
so one so what do you think tonight
what's gonna change
what do you mean what's gonna change
rotations defensive assignments maybe
uh you know switching around the
personnel forcing him off
uh off action trying to make joe ingles
um
initiate the offense they're they're
going to be they're going to be doing
things
could have seven or eight rebound uh
assists tonight and mitchell just be a
scorer
yeah i mean maybe but if mitchell's be
uh-huh
it sounds good kathy i just don't know
their track record as of late
and stopping uh superstars hasn't been
good and my guy donovan mitchell he has
to
look he's took the step hold on hold on
you guys took the step up to be called a
superstar
i i will say donovan mitchell is now a
superstar
yes but donovan mitchell stopped getting
one nothing's going to change
i'm going with the over i'm going with
the over okay what does it what is
him being six or what yeah it's a
big-time difference one didn't have to
that's a big-time difference what then
what did that has to do
in game one did did six one matter in
game one did him be at six one matter in
game one
he took 15 three-pointers bro
like they all 45 points and they only
won by three
like you had this great performance with
donovan mitchell and they only won by
three
not happening cabbie cabbie
i got wii smith i'm giving away i'm
giving i'm giving away a jersey right
here just because
i want to i just i want to give away a
jersey so why not i'm giving away a
jersey right here because
of spongebob the clippers the clippers
man i
i thought so highly of them here we go
in the comments giving away a jersey i
got we smith 44 it says 40 points
double double tonight for spider you
heard it here first
shout out to you wii smith 44 you are
walking away with a jersey he's gonna
get a jersey
yes a jersey he's he's gonna get clamped
like uh like like g-money facing garrett
cole or something like that
that not not that's not the same sport
but same result
swinging a miss i'll get a knock i'm
gonna not last week
we built our first basket parlays now
we're building first basket parlays
for tonight's double header we have uh
brooklyn and milwaukee and then we have
los angeles at utah let's take a look at
the odds for the first game
i like some of that value down low there
as you see the board
kyrie brook lopez joe harris pj tucker
solis a
professional justice tucker uh and then
let's take a look at the second games
odds donovan mitchell we're just
speaking about him plus 410
bogdanovic is nice ingo's royce o'neill
marcus morris
uh down there at uh to fill out uh the
board so
you money um left piece okay so the
audience let these odds sink in
these are some pressure filled props
because they're
resolved right away like right from the
tip boom first
possession or two g-money zero pressure
on you right now
uh but is it jersey time
it's
[Music]
got one last jersey to give out get in
the comments and tell me
who is a lock to hit first basket in
each game
aaron me and cabby's been going back and
forth
uh i want to hear you i want to hear
your take i want to hear your take who's
your
who's your who's your lock for first
basket uh parlay so for the first game
when i go with chris middleton plus 500
just feeling it obviously the bucks are
going to be at home so i'm going with
him
second game actually going with the
quietliner plus 700 finding value there
i also think since the clippers did so
well in the first half of last game they
could come out and do that again
so that's my little basket first basket
excuse me parlay
aaron i like your train of thought
they're going with the home team in the
first game i'm going to go with the
greek god giannis on to tecumbo to get
it started
for milwaukee they got embarrassing game
two this is a gut check game and they
needed to get
like if we were betting on the 10 or the
race to 20 i'd also lock in the
milwaukee bucks and in the second game
playoff p i'm going with paul george
he had a pandemic p type performance in
game one because he's only two for
fourteen
so you know i i can just imagine that
paul george either put up some shots
at an empty ymca somewhere in salt lake
city
or got to the uh the break the building
early and put up some shots today
give me paul george on a nice mid uh
mid-range or a three-pointer
to get it started for the clippers in in
the clippers and jazz game tonight
jiminy what is your two-leg first basket
parlay
cabbie before i get into my parlay i'm
gonna give out
uh hoodies and a jersey why not cause
the people are here
uh for the jerseys they're here for the
hoodies uh i have
i'm in the comments gabby i'm in the
comments and i have uh
i have wags world 10 wags world 10
they're rocking with uh they're coming
just left uh wagsworth he said kyrie
he says kyrie he did not put a parlay
together but that is okay i'm going to
give you a hoodie wagsworld he said
kyrie for the first
basket in the brooklyn game i have i
have
uh ga gang opal 796
says uh kyrie and spider he says kyren
spider
then he gave us the hunted emoji shout
out to you uh
you're walking away with the hoodie
cabbie i think it's time
to give away a jersey i think it's time
to give away a jersey i got parlay pete
in the building oh i like jp
is in the building says joe harris and
kawhi
are locked got the value get
at them a lot of exclamation points uh
and then he gave us the joe harris gif
you guys see it right there my guy joe
harris
with the splash right there there it is
uh shout out to you parley pete
you were walking away with a jersey now
let me hop in here cabbie
i'm gonna keep it real simple uh i see
milwaukee winning the tip
jana is getting the ball dribble dribble
throw it low
throw it low my guy lopez is down low
give me the bucket
there and in the other game in the other
game i got kawhi
and them kawhi clippers get the tip pass
it around a little bit nick platoon from
the corner
nick batum from the corner with the
three so give me lopez batum
uh parlay yeah i like the odds on this
giannis ayanna's and brook with lopez
pick and roll because that's basically
the only way he's
gonna be down there in the paint just
running the rim you know he's a prim
rebound rebound rebound rebound okay
yeah on a put back okay
wow your odds are crazy plus 19
seven wow that's almost plus two
thousand
uh twenty that is a crazy yeah i mean
why not throw
if we're throwing darts why not throw
you know what i mean
why not really throw a dart here for
throwing darts i might throw a dart on
all
three of us because because aaron's is
pretty is legit too that's like almost
uh it's 47 to 1. uh listen thank you so
much for
for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today
get on fanduel and bet and lock in a
first
basket parlay there's still great value
on some long shots to win the nba
championship
so you still have time if you into the
futures market
and come back next week for more hoodies
jerseys
and locks we're back next back next
tuesday
alongside aaron dolan and greg aubry my
name is cabbie richards we are leaving
the group chat
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you